winter is coming and the North remembers
Game of Thrones Season 5 episode 5
killed the boy I apologize for the
latest and the setting of this I've been
traveling on business all week so it's
been a little bit tricky for me to get
to see the episode but I now have and
there's a weird sort of juggling act
going on with stuff that I liked and
stuff that I didn't there's quite a bit
going on up in the North Sansa well
she's I'm still waiting for her to
really start doing more stuff the
situation that she's in and what's going
on around her that actually centers
rather heavily on her I'm finding
increasingly intriguing and I'm just
hoping that she gains more agency and
she's on the cusp of really finally
turning around for me she doesn't quite
yet but I'm just I'm hoping I'm so
hopeful the Bolton's i'm finding quite
interesting the relationship between
Ramsey and Roose is actually kind of
intriguing at this point some of the
insight we get into that and little
reminders of just what ruse is like but
he kind of got overshadowed with just
how bad Ramsay is and we sort of get
little reminders of it kind of is my
father likes I based off what you did to
Theon and speaking of be on now called
reek I'm I'm in a weird place with him
it's really gonna hinge on how it pays
off how well they bring what's been
going on with him to a head whatever
that head is is probably going to
heavily taint my opinion of him as a
character at this point one way or
another because right now he's kind of
riding neutral with me I'll put the wall
is where we get the most of what I have
been asking for this season which is
forward momentum I said last times like
I want more stuff to be happening but
that doesn't mean I want more action
sees I don't want superficial stuff I
want meaningful stuff to be happening
well it is started happening primarily
up at the wall because instead of just
character sitting around talking about
what they will do or what they should do
or whatever people actually start doing
things or at least they get set on the
path taking action which was that's all
that I wanted I don't need wall-to-wall
action scenes I don't need people's
heads getting chopped off I just need to
see that things are pushing forward and
we're not just spinning wheels waiting
for something more meaningful to happen
and I got that in this episode over in
murine
was a little bit weird with Daenerys I'm
having a hard time deciding what I think
about what went on with her this episode
cuz she's in an odd place and she did
things that seemed like rash emotional
decisions but she wasn't making them in
a rash emotional fashion and you know
maybe i can i can sort of intellectually
wrap my head around what they were
trying to do with that character in the
way that she was doing the things that
she did but in the moment watching and I
was like why why is she doing that why
is she doing this and like I said sort
of thinking about it afterwards i I
can't reconcile it but it that just
strikes me as a weakness and
presentation that it didn't make total
sense at the time I was watching it they
address the issue that I had before was
that stuff didn't feel like it was
moving forward unfortunately what
they've started to do is have some
really contrived things a typical show
movie whatever will really sort of take
parts of the story and twist them around
and force characters to do certain
things or force the story to go a
certain way just so that they can have
this action be have this character
interaction whatever and it's not
organic to the story and Game of Thrones
has been really good about not doing
that kind of up until this season this
episode of in particular there are a
number of things that happened I'm like
you really had to bend things around and
get into an awkward twist position to
allow that to happen and the thing that
it wasn't happening was not something
that I I was in here like oh thank god
that we now have that it was just a
thing happened and regrettably a lot of
this feeling centers around Tyrion who
unfortunately is completely superfluous
to the main story right now but we keep
coming back to him he feels very
shoehorned in right now and again I'm
hoping that you know they'll bring it
back in and they'll pay him off well but
right now it kind of feels like okay so
you saved him at the end of the lessee's
you didn't kill him for what what what
did we gain I love the character I don't
want him to die but I want him to matter
I'm still enjoying it do not get me
wrong this show has only ever had one
episode that i flat-out did not like
that was back in season three I don't
mean to be as complaining as I am I'm
still enjoying this is still
good show but you know it's too it feels
like it used to be more solid than it is
right now so I guess that about wraps it
up so on the note of what I said about
Tyrion let me ask you this is there any
character who's still kicking around
that you don't see the value in anymore
that you think well they might as well
just have gotten rid of that person if
you've got any character like that draw
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it until next time this
council is adjourned